well joining me now three political
veterans Tim bell doorbell at the
conservative razzle let Lord Russell for
the Liberal Democrats and as Campbell is
not a lord but does know which claret
and blue forty makes people I'd
certainly do as a mere boy compared to
us yeah what about that moment I mean it
was earlier on I read something about
kilometers where it should have been
miles I was just reading the AutoKey I
mean it wasn't his fault does it matter
um I think you if you're a election
candidate and you're the prime minister
I think I think it was actually more
serious than you might think because I
think it went to this idea that he's a
bit of a phony because if he okay's
reading the autocue and he sees it
coming up so it says West Ham last and
Villa I mean nobody believes is a
football supporter he sort of sprays it
on we all know he prefers polo and all
these other ridiculous
really Walter either was well this the
the urban myth about Tony and Jackie
Milburn with if that's what you're
alluding so it was just that no but my
point is if you go through I wrote a
blog about this this morning about all
his big society compassionate
conservatism leading in Europe I think
it's the same thing he doesn't actually
believe anything he doesn't stick to
anything so I thought it was the most
interesting metaphor of the campaign so
for wasn't a PR disaster it was nothing
I'll get and it says done a wonderful
job of making it sounds like a terribly
important it was absolutely unimportant
and as a production was brilliant but
the actual thing was nothing at all
most people in Britain couldn't give a
damn with rusev waterfall club well why
does he pretend they'd rather is they
respects why does anyone pretend to be
physically competent well possibly
because Nick Clegg doesn't pretend it
doesn't pretend to believe in God either
and it gets very little thanks for it
doesn't pretend to whether he believes
in God but it's not that football know
that that is sure they shot was rather
good I thought in you in your lip not
bad bloke saved he was a good safe I
suspect ninety-eight percent of the
electorate don't care what David Cameron
said on this and I don't agree with
Alistair I don't think it's symptomatic
of some or disease that the Prime
Minister has there Bing yeah I do think
people think he's a phony in location
stands at the risk that you're going to
say nothing because I know that
man you are really but has anything
interesting happening election campaign
this week and you'll not a great deal
but then has anything changed yes I
think it's moving studies Awards the
Tory majority that I predicted on the
basis of what on the basis of looking at
the polls of the effect of the incumbent
effect at the end the number of people
who are undecided
it just feels to me and canvassing
results friends of mine who are knocking
on doors it just feels a bit slowly
moving do you think I think it's
virtually unchanged since the start I
think one of the interesting things in
all the elections like remember I can
never remember as big a disconnect as to
what's going on in the so-called air war
for what's going on on the ground I was
interested that the big rally today for
David Cameron was in Yeovil which of
course was formally Paddy Ashdown
constituents and they're now David Laws
he made the point that this was one of
the twenty three constituencies he need
to work win for an overall majority what
did you make of that boast oh that's not
going to happen I think that both the
two main leaders are completely ignoring
the fact that there's no poll yet that
they showed the two of them together
having more than sixty-six sixty-seven
percent of the vote yet they're both
going around the country behaving as if
they're going for an overall majority
there is no evidence that that any of
them are either of them are going to get
it and yet they they carry on with this
pretense to the electorate that they're
going to we've had ed Miliband today say
I will do no deals I'm going for an
overall majority when everybody knows
he's not going to get no overall
majorities they're fooling the British
electorate I'll agree that III think I
was in Lancashire on Friday in
Roslindale also in Barry and not going
on quite a lot of doors and I've never
met so many um genuinely undecided
voters now for people I guess is
impossible to sort of imagine how you
can be undecided about how you're going
to vote but they were they weren't sort
of just saying I'm saying I'm undecided
but actually I'm Tory I'm Lib Dem they
were genuinely undecided and I think I I
don't agree with Tim I agree that
nothing much has moved I my sense is
that the the the Tories are kind of
throughout the throne pretty much
everything they've got and nothing has
moved I do think the one part of a
momentum that has changed in this
election so far is the sense that Ed
Miliband who started out with
people not seeing him as a credible
Prime Minister in large numbers that
that number has shifted a lot and I
think at the end what's going to happen
people are they going to fold one way
towards the conservative saying you know
what I'm going to stick with what I know
or you know what I think it Miliband can
do it and I don't think that I'll stick
with the alternative parties yes and P
liberal by yes listen there's no doubt
at all the SNP I don't need any you can
do quite as well as this whole sort of
Rockstar thing would tell us they are
doing well there's no doubt about that
let's not be silly about it I think that
the Liberal Democrats are I think you
see Tim and the way Nick Clegg yesterday
they're talking about after the match
because they've sort of given up
fighting the match and I think with you
Kip I do think for our just be looking a
bit weak but so that that maybe bit be
shifting but ultimately I think we're I
think that the smaller part is getting
squeezed a little bit because people
ultimately realize this is going to be
about Miliband in power or Cameron in
power but also there's no evidence
that's happening we've now had no lead
on decisions now is a lot of undecided
and they'll fall one way or the other
easy Tim Bob not just a question of
keeping it quiet nothing to frighten the
electorate in this week and the
Conservatives blood home or is there
work to do I think I think it's what you
just said I think the gonna stick to the
economy talk about the economy because
it's the one area where do you say and
get home triple our time maybe within
the first happened it may be the first
time view is not the first time the
audience but the what I understood said
is absolutely right that there is the
very large number of undecided but he
knows as well as I do that the undecided
for two to one in favor of the incumbent
and that's what's going to happen in the
past in the past yes but that that is
two to one in favor of the incumbents
right across the country so sometimes
labour sometimes tourists sometimes Lib
Dem I don't think the percentages or
author I suspect allister's wrong and I
think 30 to 33 percent of the electorate
will not vote for the two main parties
when we when we come to the day and if
it when it comes to Scotland and you
know I was there last week I think Alice
there was as well I mean
what can you do is there anything that
either label the concern yes yes and I
think a liberal Democrat yes I think I
think it's beginning to happen which is
that the 45% of people who voted sorry
the 55% of people who voted no need all
to get behind one particular candidate
so there'll be a lot of tactical voting
that go so I have to say Scott lot of
candidates out there and they know them
will have anything any other know but
Malcolm Rifkind loop again after on the
other side in a way that sir well I
think I found really interesting school
I was up there the same time as you and
what I found really interesting was
talking to people who said I am good of
OS MP but then said they're absolutely
aghast at the idea of a second
referendum which I did I asked me said
the SNP a pretty fast that say we're not
going here listen let's not let's not
pretend that the SNP at the leadership
level do not want to get towards that
and that's why they would I think like
are yeah he's becoming kind of Scottish
cause for a bit like you know the label
don't I don't know III think it's I
think that I also think that was playing
into the the UK politics in this I do
think there's something extraordinary
about the conservative and unionist
party leadership doing this kind of
Scotland V England thing I think is
really unpleasant I think it's quite
dangerous and I know you think the
centrosomes a just a piece of political
rubbish why it's exaggerated out of all
proportion have you ever been to England
Scotland match yeah but don't tell me
that you need to need to encourage oh
that's a totally different point isn't
it I mean the SNP have had members of
parliament for 15 years without the
Union the base also Scottish amping that
we we've just had a coalition government
isn't it a bit much for some people
who've been in a coalition government
David Cameron ort resume to those things
the biggest crisis since the abdication
had a choice ability of I think I think
sometimes when you want to make a point
you have to make it very strongly
otherwise people don't listen to you but
I would make a great different point the
interesting thing but I mean essentially
is everybody is denying everything
they're denying they're gonna do do with
these people discard and I only want to
have a referendum there do not admit
about denying this nobody believe
anything any of them are saying they all
know that what's going to come after the
election is whoever's in the
having the most suits is good of what
let me think about let me put it the
other way I mean to a certain extent you
could say the Conservatives by even
raising the possibility of a laborious
and the coalition are accepting that it
might happen so that it took years but I
mean are you saying as a someone
advising people in public relations it
would be better for any of the leaders
to come out and say look we know we're
not going to win I mean the Liberal
Democrats say that well let's as Nick
Clegg did this week with the exception
that you have to say that yeah
because in this drawing but if you think
nobody believes them would it be better
for them to tell the truth and say look
this is a no I think it would probably
be better for them to be have more
sincerity in the way they put things
across but I think it also it was all
Center he also would be much better if
you Conte ters didn't take their denials
to mean anything about that but clearly
from what Tim was saying and what
Alastair was saying the Ed Miliband
denial today of no deal with the SNP
clearly indicates that what the Tories
are doing in the laboratory marginal
seats is hurting him there otherwise he
wouldn't have said it he didn't have to
say I think what he has to do is this is
to show that he's up the up for the
fight I said this two weeks ago yeah
don't know why the troika the Tories
we've been shouting a lot today know and
to be fair but I don't know why this
always very important hope filming in
his travels you want he'll talk about
May the 8th they could find out it's are
insufficient a we call that passion but
what I want to what about looking leg
though because that Nick Clegg appears
to be inclining towards the
Conservatives whatever the rest of the
Liberal Democrats are well I'd say what
I think that when opposition's been
returning he was better Bogdan or said
it no less but I mean he was wrong was
only when he said that he could only
work with what others do it's a didn't
suit him I mean what it looks like I
suspect the result of the elections
going to be with the tour is the biggest
party so saying that so you say the only
people who the Liberal Democrats could
work with no I'm not saying that at all
he didn't say he didn't say he did he
fatally said that no well the terms of
saying Italy so effectively saying it
what he actually said is that you can't
support if if labor comes second it
would be difficult to see how
constitutionally you could support
laboring in a coalition agreement that's
what he said they wouldn't draw any
coalition that had the Scots in it they
have the Scots supporting yeah yeah we
also he ought to be constitutionally
wrong to form a government with the
party that came second rather purse
there's all sorts of with there isn't
there is no seminal institution but I
mean that's nonsense it's about winning
it is exactly
Vernon Bollinger is right about we've
argued about numbers in Parliament
before but we have indeed we agree it's
a little bit us okay but since thing he
doesn't agree well anyway you were
talking about sincerity when do you
think in honesty that Nick Clegg is
basically in Davie cameras pocket no I
think that he recognizes that the only
pocket you're going to be able to get in
is David Cameron's pocket but he needs
there to be a draw otherwise they don't
count and I see Vince Cable today says
he wants to a chance thing it does yes
well that Bali someone says he's already
got that job Josh of is deciding a party
or to singie when they're only going to
be three or four days to go